Bonjour Bonjour come on Salva Salva
Salva failure bomb you know as we get
going today you can say come on Sava or
you can say
come on Tallyho right go which is more
formal or come on VAT - all right - come
on bocce
so come on service how's it going
come on Tallyho and remember we talked
about the liaison right so come on
Tallyho it's not come on allez vous it's
come on today vous right which is more
formal or komova - is like this the more
informal to form right come on buddy
come on Sava care like how's it going
yeah how's it come on service how's it
going come on boy - how are you oh come
on tell you is a little more formal come
on telly whoo right yeah I would think
of come on come on - bah - well you want
to say come on Sava - two - you would
just say Come on Sava
meaning how is it or how is it going
come on survive how is it going what hey
in other words you say komova - is how
are you going yeah dolly who more formal
how are you going
come on Sava how is it going which is it
yeah it's more like you know but you say
you say Sarabia - uh-huh
everything good you know so it's easier
service are we serving summer wait so uh
easy is good easy is good because like
all things you know gradually add more
you don't have to have five different
variations of how are you I always take
the simplest one I stick with that right
yeah that's been my methodology - yeah
we gradually add in more so now the
other thing too that you know this is
lesson two
so obviously in French there's a number
of sort of boogeymen pronunciation could
be one gender
nouns or adjectives which we can get
into in another session is another one
but of course the verbs is some
that people struggle with and
particularly if they're confronted with
an enormous conjugation table up front
because it seems it's always seemed to
me if I'm confronted with something like
that like in Arabic there are seven
types of verbs or something apparently I
have yet to see that I have yet to see
that I just ignore that and then over
time I'll gradually become familiar with
certain patterns in the language and at
some point I'll understand why they're
seven forms of the verb and the
similarly with all the different forms
in French I just take it one bit at a
time gradually get used to one thing
though I should tell you and you have
and many things that I will explain to
you I'm sure you have already noticed
for example because you are a Spanish
speaker in French you always have to use
the pronoun I in Spanish that's not the
case right in Spanish you don't have to
say yo okay and you start to learn every
time but it's it's redundant and it's
irrelevant
if you can say that but it's just so not
necessary that you sound overly formal
when you say that usually in Spanish yes
exactly so I'm not afraid I'm trained
out of doing it I'm learning French and
and that can be pointed out but it's
also something you gradually get used to
because you start to hear phrases and
speaking phrases and inevitably in
French the pronoun is there and there's
a very good reason for that
and that is because the endings even if
they're written differently may sound
the same Thermage to Mars in Marsh
ile plural Marsh all sounds the same so
if you're not reading you do have to end
of course the context helps but in fact
we always use the pronoun but but I just
wanted to mention that that so many
things you know in different language
books they feel obliged to teach you
some aspect of the grammar in every
lesson and so you start getting more and
more of these complicated things that
describe something that you haven't yet
experienced and it becomes more and more
difficult to keep track of all these
things whereas if you don't worry about
it and
accept the fact that through regular
exposure looking upwards as we do on
link reading listening again reading
again listen again slowly these things
start to become a little bit familiar
and so you don't have to learn all these
rules or aspects of the grammar upfront
you can come back later on and and
gradually get a better and better sense
of how these things work so with that
said let's have a look at your lesson
and in particular if you have any
particular issues that you would like to
talk about so maybe you can share your
screen cool sounds good
here we go okay so I think we need to
start a taste wada 7c you've been doing
a number of different lessons in
different parts of link that's good one
should always explore yes yes I've been
enjoying the many stories they are a
really great help so it looks like I've
gone through about half of the sixth one
so let's just start at seven to start we
play with many stories of these based on
my experience they are kind of like
going to the gym as opposed to playing
sports right so you need to be fit you
need to be fit so you go to gym and and
you work on your core like I see that
the mini stories is working their core
because they have all of them and this
is to entrench its true in all the
languages they have all mmm
high frequency verbs which you need to
speak has a lot of the basic structures
of the language and I start with them
get bored explore somewhere else but I
always come back to them because however
much we you know however much we learn
and understand and speak we always need
to go back and reinforce the core the
basic structures of the language so that
the many stories are a place that I go
to over and over and over again over
over a year I always go back to but when
we're in them and were bored with them
then we want to go out and explore other
content but today we're gonna do the
mini stars okay now one thing we should
point out is that we can look at them in
sort of the
view or the sentence mm-hmm yeah and
right now I'm in sentence view I show
that maybe show on your screen or that
yeah so here's the sentence view and
then over here is paragraph view I
suppose well we call it page you because
yeah the whole page here sorry is that
the way we switch back and forth toggle
back and forth between sentence unit
page you is going to change so it could
be that someone looking at this a month
from now will find a different way of
switching back and forth but that
doesn't matter it's it's it'll be
self-evident but the main thing is that
you you have the option of reading these
as a whole page or as
mm-hmm exactly and the cool thing about
sentence for you is that it has the full
translation right here right instead of
with the page view where of course
you're gonna have your definitions to
the right right so depends on what you
want right and it's worthwhile actually
point if we go up to where it says full
text and there's a little arrow there
sorry no a little arrow beside full text
okay
drop that translation you can see if a
translation there too
Wow so you can do the whole thing the
whole translation now that's true of the
many stories because the translations
exist some other content may may not
have a translation this depends what we
call our link link content content that
we have created will tend to have
translations or tend to have a full text
the full text will always be there but
the translation may not always be there
but let's get back to the text that's
just pretty cool though that it has both
the full text and the translation right
here I didn't I never used that
functionality before and I tend not to
use it because I prefer to fight my way
through yeah well and you don't get to
create links and everything okay well
that's just for reference really but the
other thing is if we go back to the page
and if we go to sentence view now I
how do we get rid of that translation oh
there we are okay so let's go to the
next page because it's just one word
there okay so we're seeing one sentence
at a time and if you click on translate
so somebody in fact on the last video
did say that he or she would like to see
the translation of the whole thing that
not just the individual words so it
sends you the other thing is if you
click on the sound icon what happens you
mean this one right here so you guys
can't hear it because it's in my earbuds
but it was just the sentence was just
read in French so so what what we have
here is the the actual translation the
actual narration yes right from us from
a real speaker you guys sorry okay just
like every time I flip the page for
example you know ah as my first link
that's saved which really shouldn't be
saved at all it's telling me the it's
reading the words to me with the more
like text-to-speech voice so I would
like to be able to turn that off for the
sake of these lessons okay so there
should be ya settings here sorry my
practice tip where did you click on
settings I didn't know is this I had to
move our little window down here I see
this little gear here I think this is
how I would do it I haven't done this
before and there would it be this one
autoplay text-to-speech right okay cool
and there's no there do you can also
control what happens when you link you
can automatically move to the next link
you can have the link automatically
saved so there's a bunch of stuff right
again we like everything else we don't
know overlord people with information
yeah I just know that the settings exist
and you can even like down here this is
still the text-to-speech accent which is
not as you know great as having an
actual native speaker but this is
helpful to be able to try it you know
you could do a
French female or a Canadian French
female for example and the same goes for
Spanish for Portuguese you can get
different kinds of accents which for me
is very helpful with studying Spanish
right but yeah I also I do like these
two options up here like paging flipping
to the next page means that any word
that was blue aka unknown is gonna
become known when you flip to that next
page so if you don't want to do that
then you're going to want to uncheck
this box we can call this alright so we
want today we want to talk about verbs
are there any things that you find
difficult darn troubling with regard to
what verbs in French oh well where do we
begin I have read the French grammar
guide which is very helpful French
camera yes exactly yeah I went up here
just to show everyone where that is I
mean in case you can move right now that
blocks we're gonna move this guy there
so yeah over here you click on your icon
in the top right corner and then you can
go to the grammar guide and because I'm
already on French for my lesson like
French here's the language that I'm
learning right now it's gonna take me to
the French grammar guide so this is yeah
this quick quick little overview and
then over here you can pick your
category that you want so I went into
verb tenses mm-hm and French and this is
amazing I mean this is so full of
knowledge and they go over you know all
of them mean tenses I would say I don't
know if there are more tenses in French
but what I learned in Spanish is that
there are so many and many of them you
don't necessarily need to know but this
definitely causes our covers like you
know all the different present tenses
past tenses future tenses and subject
subjunctive mm-hmm the one that a lot of
English speakers have a hard time
when so I got a brief you know overview
and of the irregular verbs - which are
some of the most common verbs so I had
definitely haven't memorized like what
these endings are or anything but I read
through it to try to better understand
verbs in context so still this is where
I'm at is trying to understand you know
what tense of a verb I'm looking at you
know I I have to say that we of course
commissioned these different grammar
summaries I think it's extremely well
done the ability that you can drill into
different aspects whether it be known
their articles or adjectives or tenses
and that it's just sort of the the
description of the grammar it doesn't
contain all these annoying tests drills
and questionnaires yeah and of course
you can go to this grammar guide time
and time again as you have you know
questions about verbs or questions about
pronouns you just go to that area look
at it forget it go back to what you're
doing but I think every time you go
there you pick up something so but it's
part you know right up front to
basically absorb it all just not gonna
happen but know that I can even save
this open on a tab while I'm in a lesson
to myself that of just immediately going
to the translation for example right so
yeah that's what I've been struggling
with a little bit so anyway I gotta get
back to my lesson here some people have
also commented sometimes it's hard to
find the lesson that you were on or
whatever I always just say you know find
your way back to the library under under
the lessons tab and then here this tab
that says my lessons which might be you
know in a slightly different place with
a new version but it's gonna be the same
concept Oh any lesson that you've opened
will be in one thing too if you look at
the underneath library there is lessons
mm-hmm
sorry go back to go to my life
uh-huh well you can hear sorry you could
have done here so it's you can either
choose to look at it as lessons or as
courses uh-huh sometimes you need to go
to courses in order to find one where
you work
uh yeah yeah see I never really look at
it from here
I always for me it's just super-easy to
go straight to my lessons if I'm looking
for one that I already had opened at
some point anyway that's yeah yeah no I
agree what I just found on that if I
have so many different courses that I'm
taking lessons from I prefer to look at
it searches because I'm gonna find it
more quickly but at any rate and also
we're not gonna get it we can go on
forever yeah we have more videos coming
any page as being either on the library
I did not know that I said mind of my
lessons because that's where I want to
go and then I want to go look for stuff
in the library otherwise just anyway
from the Guru himself okay so we're
gonna hop back into East wat seven
all right so I turned off my touch
text-to-speech so that's not bothering
me and then remind me again how to
ignore this word because in the present
design it's very difficult to find a
spot where you ignore it so I just used
X perfect stroke okay yeah so now
typically as we go through of course we
get rid of the blue words mm-hmm
so what do you want me to do read the
whole sentence or just close the first
thing I do is get rid of the blue words
so do you know the meaning of the word
Buell ah this is my first time learning
it but yeah it's completely cognate with
English so I'll go ahead and say I know
that word you can go I know
up top or you hit K um if you're using
keystrokes I don't know why that's not
working
there goes No okay now do you have okay
yeah
want to talk about verbs so as we go
along here if there is a verb issue you
can mention it if there's a verb issue I
can mention it I guess I mean I think
with verbs it's just a matter of getting
used to them like the verb what's the
verb here in this first I'll read the
sentence okay okay you know play or go
big to little okay and okay pay you know
that work um no but I could guess what
it means I would assume it means like
occupied busy busy
exactly here it is I hear yes so that
that's a pretty easy one that's a
cognate right so the other thing is just
getting back to our lesson of last week
is the liaison so he plays occupant
Kabam basically a to desu
okay herb Muir is Oh Coco pay no oh no
it doesn't adjective it's la vara
e de lettres oqp see all right yeah we
won't get into it today but if that was
Ella
it is occupé we have to put another e on
the end of okay uh-huh
there's agreement for the day but we
won't want to come to you yeah he is
so just to translate the sentence for
everyone watching he is very busy every
day
wait plant Okabe phasor QP Heiser QP it
plays Oh Cooper yeah I don't don't
overdo it but don't forget yes and and
only over time and that's why I think
it's so important to listen many many
times these phrases are gonna start
running around in your brain after a
while yeah can't wait all right Kate
yes all right blue words first yeah
non booze is numerous
right I'm gonna save that one I'm gonna
mark it a three yeah you know what
that's it I just want to stop it it's a
very interesting I do the same if I see
something that I understand but of
course it's no more sounds quite a bit
different from numerous so yeah
understandable what it means but I want
to see that word again highlighted
because why don't you review my and I
reread my lessons sometimes y'all go in
and I'll just do my yellow links review
them in flashcards so I'm gonna leave
that one there so that I can go back and
hit it again so that I start to get
comfortable with the idea that the word
is known boys it's not numerals Randy
yeah exactly yeah because it's kind of
cognate kind of not because I'm also
thinking the N OMB route I'm thinking of
name Namba like exactly so that's a
different no yeah no but still you know
it's similar
no no yeah in Spanish nombre yeah okay
no numerous yeah play Anyang okay I
think meetings that's a total cognate
yeah of excess Cleon see Liam sickly on
Rana okay so should we read the whole
sentence sure okay
he led the Nam was who yum yum have X
tickly all right perfect
really great he has many meetings with
his clients right and and I again you've
left the sayers in his even though you
know what it means
oh yeah no I can be a little bit
confusing in French because same with a
see is those right there's so many of
those words in French like say as seee
or then Jun est like it is yeah and then
sit here so I like to kind of keep them
in my flashcards for a while absolutely
I think that's a smart move
yeah but I definitely understand it in
this canto
yeah but but the thing is I think the
important thing is we use these same
links for different reasons it doesn't
necessarily mean that we don't
understand the word but we want to keep
them around to review because it's all a
process of gradually becoming familiar
right yeah yeah totally
alright no blue words here should I read
it yeah please translation while you're
at it the same time yeah well whenever
you want but just people sometimes may
not know what it means
Jean ambassador Yong Yong why not
we did discuss last week I think that
the negative has this sort of double box
apart
yeah we did mm-hmm pop nimma ba member
shanem barceló Yong Yong
well Jean embossing is on them possibly
on your and we saw here that in the
previous sentence you had that as SES is
C and here you have a CES though these
right these yes it's different so we
actually this one has a four I want to
change it to a 13 yeah another thing
that you do there that I always do is I
move them back I might move something to
no and then I move it back to three yeah
and that was another thing another
commenter on the last video said like
hey it looks like I have a lot more
known words than you do and you've been
practicing longer than me you know with
the link philosophy we always tell you
like if you can understand it in a
context go ahead and mark it as known
but don't worry you can always you know
lower the status of that word and I know
it later not but the idea is to keep
moving forward keep pushing yourself and
if you can understand it in a context
generally that's when it's known
absolutely cool next page yeah
right it pants kill song and say is okay
I'm gonna let blue the words
let's hit the blue words okay kills and
I think J say it say or you say it again
you kill Kelly Kelly yeah yeah song salt
onions is or very good not what do you
think those things mean so kids it's
like they are yeah and then I guess I
already had the transit here boring yes
I would have thought but that meant
something else though
well it sounds like a cognate of
annoying but it was boring how did how
do you pronounce it on the you on me
years on New Year's right so when you
give a word so do is you write if you
think the word for night this doesn't
have anything to do with like day and
night but the sound like the nuit is
night one me is goodnight me this is on
me years on we use perfect so but one
thing I wanted to point out first of all
are you gonna keep well we won't keep
them what do you know
yeah but I mean I know I know kills okay
no I wanted to stop one time when those
phrases come up next today this one yeah
so you'll see that Cal we have all the
phrases that people have saved relating
to Kayla it may not be important here
but there are times when these phrases
are helpful is that they exist now what
I what I think is the key phrase here is
eel sauce cook okay because the Cal is K
apostrophe l l which is they feminine
plural and they feminine right that
refers to that a union because the
meetings are
feminine anything just as in Spanish
anything that ends in IO n is feminine
so the a union are feminine so here is L
salt on the years and we also see that
the only years also agrees it's feminine
masculine it's only you with an X on
your if it was eel isn't on me you but
Ella sometimes but you've got to agree
so the subject of that only years what
is on me here what is boring the reunion
the via are feminine it drenched
I already yeah I know n is feminine
years if it was the book lay leave
because it's no leave the book masculine
no diva or they leave assault on me you
with an exit there but you don't
pronounce so that's just as it's
important we're gonna get into more and
more of this agreement which is again
something that's so easy even if you
understand the principle is very
difficult when speaking to to deliver
the on the fly I mean just it's just
you're talking months here of listening
of hearing phrases of seeing phrases and
graslie you develop these habits but one
thing I wanted to point out here is ela
posh cook now karela because you got to
ease the e of the curve disappears right
in other words whatever you have an
earth night with it said if an even an
accent doesn't disappear but the even
which is pronounced as earth the
unaccented herb if it's followed by a
vowel we get an apostrophe always like
eel napa like eel an apostrophe ah he
doesn't have even a thought right weird
so eat so that but the the expression
you know he thinks that I sure Bhaskar
Bhaskar is a very useful because we're
often having to say I think you think
I think that you think that so he thinks
that they are born right so at Boeing
yes
right boss killed the thing in Spanish
is they don't do that there's no
apostrophe for missing knees in Spanish
yeah exactly I think the closest thing
in Spanish is that certain words that
are supposed to begin with the words
that are supposed to be feminine but
they start with an A for example change
to masculine like el agua instead of la
guerre right as you get that double a
sound or the double vowel stop it just
sounds awkward for that Latino year
that's my theory
all right okay all right so what you can
do is on yours you're gonna save it I'm
gonna save that one go ahead and mark
that as a three you know it's also
important to save it even if you
understood the meaning just that way
because if it encompasses the agreement
there and on the is a bit difficult to
pronounce anytime I have a word that I
want to just keep around your flashcard
doing for whatever I'll just keep it
I cannot good you know whatever I can
get rid of it later on I'm sorry
my main motivation when I'm linking in a
lesson is to get rid of the blue I don't
like seeing blue words on my page they
just whiten yellow I'm improving I'm
good yeah cool all right blue word
sertão some certain that sounds pretty
straightforward yeah they all saw on ego
Eimi Cole I friendly amicable okay
yeah that's good I'm gonna mark that us
three okay all they're towards mmm but
that doesn't mean anything to me we're
gonna mark that as a two right sometimes
you know all there is a very useful word
yes I can imagine
yeah so I sometimes early on key
connector words key prepositions words
that I really need the structure stuff I
might tag them something to do maybe
later on I mean I mean add a tag here
yeah UK oh I see I see like um Oh what
do you want to call that like a common
word um you could and I've never even
added a tag before okay I'll think of
something else that you can but it's
just to indicate that it is available
because then later on you can look at
them in the vocabulary section and
they're all be collected for you because
is that something that you generally
recommend doing is taking tend to Tigers
early on in the language everything is
just confusion and so I will even start
by tagging like verb know like if start
I started into a language I don't know
Greek or Parisian I don't even know
what's a verb what's on now and so to
start to make ordering what I'm hearing
and reading I sort of tag certain basic
you can always get rid of tag later on I
find that there is a stage and then like
agreement you know might be something
that will be difficult for people in
French so I would have a tag perhaps for
agreement
I had tags for different cases in
Russian so that the advantage of that is
you then collect these so that when you
go to the vocab section you can search
or sort rather all of your save links by
these tags or you see ten examples of
this kind of verb or this kind of not so
in you know I'm sometimes my tag like
things that describe emotions or you
know I mean you're gonna find that
pronouns create a problem in French as
the you in Spanish I might tag phrases
you can even tag phrases phrases that
have pronouns in them so you get sort of
a concentrated exposure to
but let's let's read this sentence okay
all right here we go
sit down Cleon saw amico and Valjean
okay so septic Leah certain set a clear
clear song so right now we got to make
sure that that if it's a that Leo's song
now that sounds obvious but again it's
difficult we used to is is a certain
Cleon a no-no certaintly on song right
so we have to graduate get used to use
the right verb and because it's plural
its amico oh my god because it was
luckily on Adam II can write if it's one
client but it's certainly also amico
oh there's on all their song writer
Georgia some customers are really
friendly to Jean don't see us the first
word you know that word so yeah I know
other no no before that
Oh nom nom Wong mm-hmm why is that word
not blue that's right that's right so
things can happen you can sometimes you
know move to know you know and move the
page to know I'll probably page you left
something behind
yeah it's never a problem you can always
go back and reclaim it and the
statistics adjust my is a very
sophisticated work that actually yeah is
it not commonly used it's not so common
like there's so many different words
like I would say that and I call those
connector words see nevertheless
although because those are all the words
you need that connect connect words and
phrases you could use sip on dong coming
but here they use neon wine which is
nevertheless nevertheless okay so you
would recommend I just save it as
nevertheless here nevertheless it's not
however in fact it's it's nevertheless
basically okay cool
no no there we go I'm gonna keep that as
a one okay II or and y'all tears
daughters don't know ass you don't
pronounce the S Dhokla don't dolphin the
others some others some others sometimes
the sense of some some others don't
you'll see that implies some beaucoup de
Jean means it has a sense of of quantity
I won't say more because you'll
gradually get you said yeah Tamizh some
others okay
there's a there's a table right it was
that pronunciation okay it's not be a
blur
there's a gray Alba alright so that's
pretty common
um pretty similar to just finish I'm
still gonna steal victim okay so oh this
is interesting the translation leaves
out the word nevertheless I know that's
a problem but yeah I mean what can
happen here is the English translation
comes from the original story in English
because all of the many stories
originated in English the person who
decided to translate them into French
probably felt that it would make more
sense if we threw in the word
nevertheless mm-hmm one of these are all
and so people shouldn't get bent out of
shape over this languages are imprecise
at times nothing is perfect
the translation won't be perfect there's
a lot of stuff like that we just move on
we have and I'm sorry we have to accept
a certain amount of fuzziness yeah and I
mean everyone interprets language their
own way too so
that's why you know from one language to
the other language a translation is
never going to be perfect it's never
going to be word for word because it's
all the interpreter of the person who's
making the interpretation absolutely
okay we you know okay let's go one more
line and then we look at the whole page
view okay okay yeah sure riveting okay
Skype oh yeah should I read it yeah John
Condon longer pauses Visionnaire O's
paused is your name right sure okay the
longer pout poses Oh pause write out
those pause okay break do you agree with
these break pause in our mission yeah
that's exactly what it means
okay cool I'm gonna
and that can be a three dish in there
right I understand as eating breakfast
or eating lunch
okay now yeah lunch is smoke so what's
interesting here is that in Canada in
Quebec dejeuner can mean breakfast and
as in Spanish they say you know like in
English days your name is to break the
fast right yeah yeah yeah run is a fast
so de journee would mean normally
breakfast but in France
it means lunch notice that and some of
the other lessons I did I was like but
wait is it breakfast or lunch the
breakfast in France is called petit
dejeuner small breakfast and France is
the petit dejeuner okay okay do but but
da it varies all over the place so how
would you say lunch and Quebec well you
know I haven't spent much time there
then they also use the word dejeuner but
they might use the word DNA as well it's
all in English some people say dinner to
mean lunch
some people say dinner to mean supper
depends on the time of day you eat -
yeah totally
like I was gonna have to northern
Alberta and I thought I was going to
dinner and they were expecting it lunch
oh okay so then dinner was dinner was
lunch and for me dinner is evening time
it sounds like you arrived a little bit
late then - so you might want to save
the word dejeuner and this is like this
is the noun form right it's not a verb
no you can also designate but this is
the noun form right jean takes long
lunch breaks aha but but this pose
dejeuner you gotta say this is lunch
break yeah so I wanted to save them
individually and separately is that okay
yeah okay cause so that'll be a two
and then lunch breaks really good phrase
to have yeah now the other thing to
remember yeah au is oh okay oh oh it's
not like it's not like in Spanish may
use oh okay there's a town in France
called PO PA u PO pop oh okay like
beaucoup right let me write whoa so au
is oh so the other thing DeLong the
poles right so again you see the use of
dirt in a sense of quantity all right
mm-hmm now what I'm gonna do if I see
you the word pong let click on the word
call
that's what huh yeah and you'll see that
it's the present tense we've got various
potential tags there all right so you
could click on this as verb you can
click on it as pong
lol so these are potential these are in
fact these are already tagged for this
these are automatic tags if you were to
go to your vocab section you could look
it up under those tags or you can add
another tag now the other thing I wanted
to show will go to the check manage
dictionaries okay if you and I we move
this guy it's kind of blocking my view
of it sorry yeah if you go to look so
there are two conjugating dictionaries
that you can use go to the lower section
okay ah sorry go back up to the top I
saw it there to my mind the best
conjugating dictionary is reverse or
verb conjugator the third one one up
there we go you can also go to look on
you girl but I don't find it as good so
here if you go through that move up a
little scroll down you'll see that it
highlights the one you're on right yeah
and it shows you other you know the rest
of the conjugation of this verb I find
that very useful to do because let's be
honest we're not going to remember that
the third person has no s and chiron to
has an S we will remember it now because
you're looking at it or later on you're
gonna forget it and so I
that it's very useful when I get to a
verb I go to the conjugating dictionary
I look at a specific form of the verb
that I'm on and I also glanced over the
other stuff I'm not gonna remember at
all but it's all part of gradually
getting used to how that verb works so
we could have done this with when we had
like a like it so that every time you're
on LA or LA you can click on that go to
the contact the conjugator reverse or
dictionary and see the full range of you
know conjugations and also if you have
doubts you know is this you know
subjunctive or what tense is it or
whatever it will take you to the spot
this is what you're looking at so I find
it very useful and that kind of regular
review is helpful to gradually gradually
get a sense awesome great to know
yeah it's useful one thing I would like
to do now and we'll kind of end this is
go back to the lesson view the page
rather that page here so if we go back
to the previous page so this is what I
like to see we have no more blue words
we have a lot of white words some yellow
words I can even very quickly review
those yellow words on that page or and
we're not gonna do that today I could go
through them in flashcards so the
process is one of making the pages more
and more white and yellow and and then
of course listening listening and
typically here I would put this to a
playlist so that is part of the things
that I'm regularly listening to and
Steve could you actually show me how to
do that how to add this to my playlist
sure so because I normally do this on my
iPad let us have a look here let's go to
the to the body McCallum here these
three dots the three dots there ah okay
had to play now
cool is it that simple that's simple
now one thing you can do on my iPad when
my course comes up they have a thing
there called play course audio okay
so that what would then happen is that
all these 60 stories come up as a
playlist on my iPhone mm-hmm so then I
can listen to them and I can jump in
wherever I want I can scramble them I
can do whatever I want
go to click on where it says link many
stories so you got the lesson list under
where you save course audio all right
let's get out of that that's not the
place let us click on one of these wok
video can you scroll downwards as sunny
no yeah it's not there it's somewhere on
the right hand side okay let's try
something else as I don't do it I do it
on my iPhone okay
from the gear you think try that try
that again no no it's not in here no no
no playlist settings I don't think so
audio no playlist sighs no no and what
is that that you're trying to do well
it's still early for you but if I've
gone through 15 or 20 lessons in a
course rather than saving each one to my
playlist which I can do oh you want to
like math I just I phone and I just say
play course audio and then I have my
iPhone with me all of the lessons in
that course and actually I don't know if
that's what I already have here and my
app
but I might be able to show that really
quickly okay yeah like this is my
playlist can you see it
oh I'm let me just move that forward
here okay it's so hard for me to say
yeah I think so yeah and honestly I
don't remember adding any of these to my
playlist I think that they these were
lessons you know we're discovering this
I think mark set it up now so that any
lesson that you have studied is on the
place I think that's how it works too
yeah I can double-check with him but I
didn't add any of those myself so I
didn't okay that's good yeah okay well
mark before we discover more things that
I don't know about so the key then is to
keep listening reading and try to save
up any questions that you have any
difficulties that you have okay and then
next time we can try to focus in on some
of those could you I know where we need
to wrap up here but could you give me
like a quick study guide for what you
recommend for me for the next couple
weeks or for the next week because for
example one thing I've heard from you in
your videos is reading and listening
reading and listening so I wonder should
I be reading the lesson and listening to
it at the same time or is it more a
matter of listening when I'm doing other
things and then coming back to read
afterwards typically what I do is I
begin by listening if if it's a language
that's very difficult but for me I
Arabic or Persian then I will begin by
listening and reading at the same time I
don't have a chance but otherwise it's
just to me it I do what's convenient and
it's easier just to pick it up and start
listening and so as I listen of course a
lot of it I don't understand so then I'm
very motivated to like what exactly was
that so then I go back in and read it
and then I listen again so I don't think
there are any hard and fast rules I find
that because listening is so easy to do
I do the listening first it triggers my
curiosity I'll go back in and I read and
I save words particularly early on in
the language I will flashcard as I go
from page to page
I will sometimes go through sentence by
sentence while listening and it's
particularly convenient with the mini
stories because we actually have
timestamp it so you can hear that each
sentence pronounced right and I think
that's very good so you could go through
sentence by sentence listening to each
sentence saving as you go then you go
away and you listen to the whole thing
you thought you understood it now you
listen to it all as one big lesson you
don't understand it now so you go back
and you read it again and you're gonna
have to be doing that a lot especially
in the initial period because your brain
has to get used to French or Spanish
helps you in terms of vocabulary and
cognates but it doesn't help you in
terms of getting used to the sounds and
the rhythm of French so I would
recommend go sentence view listening to
it choosing words and then go and listen
and then go back in and read again maybe
do some flash guarding if you're going
page you because is if you're doing
sentence you there's only like two links
is not worthwhile but page view do some
more flash guarding to focus in on those
words that you want to spend more time
on go away and less center and and you
know lesson one to ten if you end up
because you're going one two three four
five up to ten back to one back up to
ten if you listen to them ten times
that's not too many and you'll find that
as you move on to twenty and thirty and
forty you'll still be going back to
lesson one because there will still be
things in Lesson one that you didn't
really totally notice or get used to and
at the end of the sixty like those sixty
lessons that's good for two months
that's not to say you don't go and
explore other stuff but I find myself
always going back to the many stories to
really you know develop those solid
habits in the language I don't know
ya know it's very helpful thanks and I
think next week could be a good idea for
us to show the flashcards and what your
review method is exactly okay thanks
[Music]